[Musica]
buonasera in questi ultimi 20 anni ho
girato il mondo con l'organizzazione
mondiale della sanità nei quattro angoli
del globo
però questa oggi vi voglio parlare di
qualcosa che è accaduto qui a treviso
ripensando a radici e futuro
mi vengono in mente risorse e
prospettive
tutto sommato sono gli agganci logici
piove beh vediamo come siamo messi a
risorse in italia per quanto riguarda il
finanziamento in rapporto al pil per la
ricerca sanitaria
noi siamo messi qui beh siamo dietro il
portogallo però siamo davanti a malta ea
romania e se andiamo a vedere nel corso
del tempo come si muove il finanziamento
del ministero della salute nei confronti
degli istituti come il mio che sono il
resort ospita gli ospedali di ricerca
che dovrebbero portare avanti la ricerca
sanitaria in italia
vedete che c'è un decremento di circa il
10 15 per cento per anno questo se lo
proiettate rispetto al numero degli
istituti che ricevono finanziamenti si
traduce in un ulteriore più profondo
peggioramento a fronte di questo però la
produzione scientifica non è diminuita
anzi nel corso degli anni è aumentata ma
com'è possibile
beh potrebbe essere successo quello che
è successo anche a me tutto comincia con
una visita una visita medica e una
diagnosi una ragazzina di 12 anni che
cammina in modo goffo cade
frequentemente a problemi di
coordinazione il sospetto diventa una
certezza quando la analisi molecolare
conferma che si tratta di una malattia
neurologica progressiva l'atassia di
friedreich ma questa diagnosi che per me
poteva essere la parola fine conclusiva
a un processo e per la famiglia
sicuramente un momento drammatico si
trasforma in una richiesta di risposte
che cos'è l'atassia di friedreich tratta
sia di friedrich è una malattia
degenerativa rara 1 su 50 mila circa
colpisce agli adolescenti
prevalentemente
con una progressiva perdita di
coordinazione che li porta in serie
rotelle nel giro di dieci anni colpisce
il cuore la vista l'udito e non c'è
nessuna terapia disponibile
allora che ricerca posso fare per una
malattia di questo tipo che cosa posso
inventarmi per risolvere un problema di
questo genere
la ricerca è presente e attiva nel mondo
ci sono filoni questi sono i diversi
filoni e ricercati va però se voi
guardate quali di questi filoni
raggiunge il tetto quindi va più in alto
quindi raggiunge gli studi clinici e
sono davvero molto pochi perché molte
ricerche si perdono nel passaggio dal
laboratorio al letto del paziente ma
anche perché noi siamo terribilmente
inefficienti nel riuscire a leggere il
risultato di una ricerca cioè nel
riuscire a capire se quelle quella cura
quel trattamento funziona o no la
malattia come vi dicevo è progressiva
che vuol dire che nel corso degli anni
io perdo qualcosina aperto qualcosina
poco poco nel corso di molti anni quindi
per vedere una grossa differenza io ho
bisogno di molti anni uno studio clinico
dura in media un anno massimo due anni
proprio nei casi più eccezionali
beh per questa malattia usando le scale
cliniche che utilizziamo normalmente per
vedere una differenza di meta nella rete
di progressione quindi della velocità di
caduta ho bisogno di quasi 600 pazienti
cosa che per una malattia rara è
pressoché impossibile anche con studi
multicentrici e allora nasce l'idea
perché non sperimentiamo un modo per
leggere meglio le variazioni nei brevi
tempi e utilizziamo per esempio le
tecniche avanzate di neuroimaging che
possono darci un insight all'interno di
quello che normalmente non vediamo
nasce quindi questa ricerca e nasce con
il supporto finanziario di una piccola
associazione che è stata creata dai
genitori di quella bambina che io vive
nel 2010 questa ricerca porta a capire
che non solo la struttura del cervello
dei pazienti con questa malattia è
leggermente diversa se guardata con gli
occhi della tecnologia più avanzata
ma se questo cervello viene fatto
funzionare quindi vi chiedo ai soggetti
per esempio di muovere un dito
all'interno del dello skal si accendono
posizioni luoghi diversi nel cervello in
modo diverso rispetto ai controlli
questo potrebbe essere un indicatore
potrebbe essere qualcosa che si è
prevedibile probabile possibile che si
modifichi in un tempo breve
sei mesi i sei mesi che abbiamo previsto
di utilizzare per testare intanto questa
sostanza che una sostanza come un'altra
però che potrebbe avere un effetto lo
studio iniziato nel giugno del 2016 si
conclude questo mese avremo i primi
risultati nel 2017
ma al di là di quello che dirà questo
studio è il principio che ha vinto ed è
una partnership e si è creata con
effetti collaterali per esempio il fatto
che abbiamo avuto un'affluenza
straordinaria di pazienti con questa
malattia e questo ha fatto sì che ci
siamo chiesti visto che siamo un
istituto che fa riabilitazione ma è mai
possibile che non possiamo nel frattempo
provare a risolvere dei piccoli problemi
dio nella vita di tutti i giorni che
questi ragazzi incontrano per esempio la
capacità di risollevarsi da terra una
volta caduti
sembra banale ma per loro è un'impresa e
se io non sono sicuro di risollevarmi da
terra se cado non vado fuori allora se
io riesco a insegnarti una strategia per
far questo ti cambia la vita
certo non cura la malattia ma ti cambia
la vita e posso magari provare a vedere
se utilizzando tecniche di
neuromodulazione per esempio innocue
magari potenzia gli effetti di un
trattamento riabilitativo
e ancora i miei dati nel frattempo
raccolti con metodologia e sistema
possono essere impiegati per dare
maggior peso a network internazionali
come questo ad esempio enigma è un
grosso network di neuroimaging quindi di
immagini di risonanza magnetica che a
livello mondiale raccoglie pazienti con
questa specifica malattia e siamo già
oltre 300 pazienti raccolti
certo ci sono anche eventi avversi cioè
eventi che vorrei evitare ma che possono
presentarsi
intanto la possibilità che la stretta
correlazione tra committente e
ricercatore crei
sorta di ricerca la cart dico io ce di
una personalizzazione eccessiva della
richiesta che toglie libertà ricercatore
e che chiude gli orizzonti gli orizzonti
della ricerca
inoltre trattandosi di piccole
associazioni che non hanno grandi basi
finanziarie
chiaramente la possibilità di fare studi
di grandi dimensioni con alti costi è
estremamente piccola e quindi c'è una
riduzione delle ambizioni di ricerca
dall'altra parte la assenza di un
comitato che selezioni a monte le
ricerche stesse può diventare un
elemento che toglie qualità e
competitività alla ricerca stessa
indipendentemente che da questo però la
creazione di una partnership è un
elemento estremamente nuovo almeno per
me non è una cosa nuova in senso
assoluto certamente ma che modifica il
modo di vedere dei ricercatori intanto
rispetto a quello che fa facendo capire
che il mio lavoro è non solo la ricerca
di cose nuove ma è la risposta ad un
bisogno un bisogno che sentito
fortemente da chi mi sta di fronte
e la ricerca quindi diventa non solo un
avanzamento scientifico ma diventa un
bene pubblico che io condivido con una
comunità alla quale comunità però
dall'altra parte risponde e risponde in
che modo finanziando raccogliendosi
attorno ad una idea e cercando di
sostenerla questo sistema non è un
sistema nuovo più ha detto un sistema
che esiste il cofinanziamento cioè il
fatto che un finanziamento privato venga
poi accoppiato ad un finanziamento
pubblico è uno schema presente nei bandi
di ricerca per esempio ministeriali
quelle di cui stiamo aspettando in
questi mesi anche in queste settimane
direi il risultato
questo bando per esempio di cui stiamo
aspettando per l'appunto il risultato
oggi è stato bandito nel giugno del 2016
questo è il problema il problema di
molti di questi schemi pubblici e che
hanno delle durate temporali
assolutamente incompatibili con una
ricerca che vuole essere di avanguardia
18 mesi
un'idea non può stare in incubatore
dobbiamo tirarla fuori
vorrei concludere con questa diapositiva
che mi è stata mandata da un amico da un
collaboratore che lavora a varanasi in
india in india qualche settimana fa si è
celebrato il di quali gli uguali e la
festa del ritorno di rama il dio rama
dalla oscurità e riporta la luce nel
mondo in ogni casa si costruiscono
queste immagini floreali si
arricchiscono con le luci e ogni casa
festeggia la prosperità che arriva la
luce che torna il mio augurio che la
luce davvero torni e continui a
splendere a treviso e anche altrove
grazie
[Applauso]